le festival de cannes avec ce soir le
nouveau film de pedro almodovar tout sur
ma mère
curieusement c'est la première fois que
pedro almodovar fait partie de la
sélection officielle
les fans du cinéaste espagnol n'ont pas
été déçus le délire dans les couleurs
les situations et les dialogues est
toujours aussi présent même si ces
dialogues sont parfois un peu cru en
tout cas le public a été séduit pascal
deschamps et bruno livertout voilà un
homme qui sait parler aux femmes sans
vous par ce nul de femmes des femmes
comme ulik faut dire que pedro almodovar
a offert ses quatre actrices des rolling
l'une joue un travesti qu une autre une
actrice homosexuels la troisième une
religieuse qui tombe enceinte la
dernière une infirmière qui perd son
fils de 17 ans les situations extrêmes
et un scénario sur le fil du rasoir pour
ce film avec lequel pedro almodovar
voulait rendre un subtil hommage aux
femmes la montréalaise
oui c'est un film dédié aux femmes aux
maires aux femmes qui aimeraient être
mère ne le sont pas alors que l'on nous
sommes qu'ils aimeraient être des femmes
et aux actrices qui jouent des rôles
d'actrice
d'une manière générale je crois qu'il
est dédié tout le genre féminin nous
postons la compta d'auto tune in fine
elle aussi est ce qu il fait tout comme
à l'arrière et leurs comparses ont
installé tôt car elle nous avait
toujours c'est tellement fort l'histoire
qu'il faut le faire avec absolument avec
naturalité total avec un simply city
total avec 1
comment dire une phrase il était totale
mais avec migrent and co courage
estampillée cinéaste de la transgression
almodovar manier aujourd'hui plus
qu'hier l'émotion autant que l'humour
mais son discours n'a pas changé nous
sommes des êtres multiples il faut nous
accepté comme tel
allez-vous tandem la tête lors des
camions et loquace almodovar regarde les
femmes avec un regard de femme
il comprend exactement ce que nous
ressentons car ils acceptent de la part
féminine qui est en lui
ok au maroc benchikha points thomas
préval est à la base un casting
en fait la maman de pedro almodovar ne
veut toujours pas aller voir les films
de son fils dommage car contrairement à
ce que le titre laisse supposer tout sur
ma mère ne dévoile aucune indiscrétion
sur sa vie privée